So let's add a little Flair to this game cuz
right now we just have hard coded numbers in
so every time we attack no matter what I'm
going to win because the villain's health is
going down
a much faster rate than mine so we need to
add some sort of random factor to this
project
Let's head over to our JavaScript and I'll
show you all let's head over to our
JavaScript and I'll show you how to do just
that
So from here I'm going to add that section
tag as well so we'll see section
Hero let's get rid of this debugger we don't
need this anymore
So the main important part is we have these
two checks here at the top we want to
keep these at the top cuz we don't want any
code to run if it hits this
But after that let's create a new variable
that's going to essentially be that Heroes
attackSo let's say let hero attack.
And I want this to equal
Math.random this is going to be a JavaScript
function that's built in
And I'm just going to multiply this by 10
for now
And let's go ahead and cancel out this for
nowWe want to apply it though.
Cuz I do want to show off one thing that's
going to be kind of a problem
So let's open up our consoleI want to tag.
So right now we see that we have our hero
attackAnd it's 1.4333 and it's always going
to give me a random number.
Between 0There's a good one zero and 10 I
actually got two.
very high rolls it's very low chance to get
a 9.979.02But it's just going to be a random
number between those.
And that's what I want my and that's what I
want my hero to be able to take I wanted to
be able to attack in between 0
And 10But right now we're getting those long
integer numbers so the way a quick.
way to fix that is we can also use another
JavaScript function called math.flora
So if we save that and head back to our Dom
From here we can see in my hero text 96852
And we can keep going so we got a zero
And we actually defeated but there is one
problem now because of the math.4
Is that it will can never be 10It can only
be zero through nine so after this.
So let's go ahead and just change this to 11
Let's check it out here
Cuz Matt thought floors always going to
round down to the nearest number and sweet I
got my tender
And I should still be able to get a zero
awesome perfect
And there are other ways to do this there's
also going to be a math dot ceiling
Maybe notMaybe I'm just remember. Yeah just
act like I never said that.
So awesome from here I have my hero
attackAnd when my hero attacks.
I wanted to crease the bosses the villains
help not by 10:00But I actually wanted to
crease the villain's Health by.
The amount in my hero attack
So one important thing that I kind of
switched up here is my villain Health should
go down when I attack
In my hero hell should go down when the
villain attacks essentially
It will change this to villain healthInstead
of going down by 10:00 here let's actually
say.
Sign it toThat variable we created which is
going to be a random number.
So now if we come back to our application we
can see it goes down by 85.
And then six it's going to always be a
random numberTo this point.
It's going to be completely random if I can
actually defeat the bossAnd. I couldn't beat
him.
But we do come into another issue that we're
having here is the hero health is at 5:00
when we want to be at zero
But that's also because of the place that we
have are
Hero Health going down now because it's
actually in the bottom portion of it
So we'll fix that once we get back to
calculating our villains damage as well
So from here I'm going to do the same thing
with my villain
Let's say let villainAttack. Equal. We'll
start with that math up for.
And we'll use that random generator cuz this
is like say this is going
to map out random will randomly generate a
number between 0 and 1
And that's why we need to multiply it by
either the 10 or 11
But in this case I'm not going to do 11 I'm
actually going to make it so the boss can
attack from 0 to 60 to 15
He's got a little bit more damage
And we'll have the hero Health go down by
that attack
So let's go ahead and get rid of some of
these console logs as well at this point
We know they are doing exactly what we
wanted to do so there's really no point in
keeping in there
SweetSo let's refresh and when we attack
now.
We see that we're both attacking each other
for a completely random numbersAnd he smoked
me dang.
So I want to add something in here
For when the hero's Health actually goes to
zero so we'll do the same thing we'll say
If Our Hero's health is less than or equal
to zeroWill pop that alert as well.
We'll just say oh no the code Works Crusader
has vanquished
Well actually making a little will slain by
the coatingVirus. And we'll say.
RipIt's not we go back to our web
application.
If we lose again hopefully we get thatOh no
the code works great dang he hit me hard.
Wait a secondHe isn't dead.
What's going on man
So right now when I click through this
gameYou can see there's a little bit of an
air there with the heroes health.
And that's because it's not getting
drawnTill I click on the bun the next time.
And this air is kind of occurring due to a
couple reasons but the main reason
Is that I have a lot of code here just all
created inside of one function
This would be the definition of not clean
code
There's a lot of things we can refactor into
other functions
Cuz right now we have pretty much three
functions all written to this one right now
we have
an attack by our hero you have an attack bar
villain but we also have these draws
happening
As well and that's where this conflict is
happening we need to create a function for
those first two things but we also need to
create that function for